thanks to surf shark for helping support
this episode
hey crazies black holes seem like the
ultimate absorbers
if something crosses the event horizon
it's trapped
it'll never interact with anything in
our universe again
given that you'd expect a black hole to
be absolute zero
but it isn't the space time around them
emits hawking radiation
and that radiation is surprisingly
thermal
what's hawking radiation okay fine but
just the quick version
contrary to popular belief this is not
what a black hole looks like
they're not holes in a flat plane
they're actually spheres
they're balls black balls in
space they completely enclose a certain
amount of space
a space from which nothing can escape
ever the outer edge of that space is
called an event horizon
that's just a boundary we can't see
beyond
but plenty of stuff escapes from just
outside that boundary
usually that stuff is emitted by
in-falling matter
these accretion disks as they're called
can emit light across
the em spectrum from radio waves all the
way up to x-rays
they can even emit matter in the form of
astrophysical jets
but even if a black hole doesn't have
one of those discs around it
it'll still emit light the space itself
emits that light
no in-falling matter necessary it's
called hawking radiation
because it was predicted by stephen
hawking back in 1974.
i have a whole video on how that works
if you want to check it out later
what matters today is the pattern we see
in it
brightness or intensity patterns and
light can give us a feel for it
if we see something like this we know
the light is just reflected off a
surface
this pattern is light emitted due solely
to temperature
this one has quantum origins so what
kind is hawking radiation
the temperature kind wait black holes
have a temperature
apparently yes
these days thermodynamics is the study
of energy exchanges on the atomic and
molecular level
but it didn't start that way to the
timeline
thermodynamics began as the study of
pressure volume and temperature
in 1662 robert boyle published a law
relating pressure and volume
in 1780 jacques charles discovered a
relationship between
volume and temperature he didn't publish
it though
joseph louis galassac confirmed the
result and published it in 1802
crediting jacques for the discovery at
least there's some honor among science
thieves
anyway at the same time joseph also
published a law relating pressure and
temperature
which was ultimately named after him
they wouldn't be combined into a single
law
until 1834 by emil
by emile clapper clapeyron clapper raw
you can do it oh the french names are
gonna be the death of me
by emile kleperron but these laws only
apply to gases
not liquids or salads so we already knew
we were missing
something let's rewind a bit back in
1702
guillaume omontong suggested a value for
the minimum possible temperature
an absolute zero his suggestion was
negative 400
degrees fahrenheit or negative 240
degrees celsius
which is honestly impressively close
this idea would later become known as
the third law of thermodynamics
in 1749 amelie du chalet derived the
conservation of energy for the first
time
ever conservation of energy shall not be
violated
it was commentary she wrote in the
margin as she was translating newton's
book into french
unfortunately she doesn't get a lot of
notoriety because she was a woman
in science conservation of energy
wouldn't be officially recognized until
almost a hundred years later
when hermann von helmholtz published it
as the first law of thermodynamics
in 1824 sadie carneau laid the
groundwork for the second law of
thermodynamics
which rudolph klausis formalized in 1850
with his concept of entropy
aren't there four laws of thermodynamics
yes but the zeroth law wasn't added
until 1936
the zeroth law hey look i i didn't name
it okay
it essentially defines how thermometers
work so everyone wanted it to be the
first on the list
but it was way too late to renumber the
other three hence
zeroth just go with it what's important
about these laws
is they don't just apply to gases they
apply to all substances
gases liquids and solids physicists like
it when rules apply to as many things as
possible
and the craziest thing about this is
that these laws of thermodynamics
also apply to black holes
if we're going to measure the
temperature of anything we're going to
need some kind of thermometer
you know that thing we were just talking
about with the zeroth law of
thermodynamics
everyday thermometers like that use
something called heat conduction
you put in the thermometer and energy
moves directly from whatever is hotter
to whatever is cooler
until thermal equilibrium is reached at
that point you get a reading from an
expanding fluid or
from a digital heat sensor that is
unless you have one of these
they actually detect the infrared light
from things like your forehead
it doesn't have to be your forehead
though it could really be anything in
the range of the sensor
boom boom
boom boom
boom boom
i love this thing anyway the light isn't
limited to infrared that just
happens to be what most everyday objects
are emitting
light bulbs are so hot they emit visible
light
empty space is so cold it emits
microwave light
it depends on temperature which is why
it can be used as a thermometer
and it's the only thermometer available
for things in outer space
it's how we know the surface temperature
of the sun is 5 800 kelvin
and it's how we know black holes are
crazy cold
sure that the infalling matter can get
hot but the black holes themselves
are really cold at most we're talking 20
nano kelvin
that's 20 billionths of a kelvin
for comparison the background
temperature of empty space
is 2.73 kelvin that's whole kelvins
not nano kelvins the background
temperature of the universe
is a hundred million times hotter than
the hottest black hole
which is why none of them are shrinking
yet the extreme
freeze of the vacuum is too hot
but if black holes have a temperature
then it stands to reason they should
obey the four laws of thermodynamics
and they do it's just that they they do
it in a way that's a little
counterintuitive let's say you preheat
an oven and then you put a pan inside it
the oven air is hot it's much hotter
than the pan
our instincts tell us that the pan will
heat up the air
gives it heat no no no no don't touch it
there you go safety first just like the
pan
black holes can exchange energy with
their surroundings
they can absorb energy by eating and
they can release it through hawking
radiation
in both cases energy is conserved
conservation of energy shall not be
violated
that means black holes obey the first
law of thermodynamics
it's their temperature that's
counter-intuitive we'd expect this
eating growing black hole to get hotter
because it's absorbing energy but it
doesn't it gets cooler
black holes cool down by eating and they
heat up
by emitting hawking radiation what what
what
i know i know it sounds like crazy talk
but it's what our model for hawking
radiation tells us
remember that thermal radiation curve
from earlier well when we plot out
hawking radiation for black holes of
various sizes
they look like this the bigger black
holes emit lower frequency light
and less light overall the only logical
conclusion
is that bigger black holes are colder
than smaller black holes
this doesn't break the zeroth law though
they do still find thermal equilibrium
with their surroundings
it just doesn't happen until they
completely evaporate
this temperature pattern also helps them
obey the third law
that's the one that says nothing can
reach absolute zero
it's the minimum temperature black holes
can get very cold
but they'll never reach absolute zero
which makes sense
for a black hole to be absolute zero it
would have to be infinitely big
wait no no no the universe is not a
black hole
okay so what about the second law oh
it's obeyed too
but that's a giant can of worms i don't
want to open right now
don't worry i'm going to do a whole
video on it the point is that
all four laws of thermodynamics are
obeyed by black holes
we know they have a temperature because
the light they emit matches a thermal
curve
most of the light is extreme radio waves
though because they're very very cold
the smallest stellar mass black holes
are only about 20 nano kelvin
that's a hundred million times colder
than the background temperature of the
universe
the supermassive black hole at the
center of our milky way galaxy
is only 15 femtokelvin that's
over a million times colder than the
smallest stellar mass black holes
black holes are the coldest things in
the universe
well except for maybe regional licensing
deals
this video sponsor surf shark can help
with that
surf shark is a vpn or virtual private
network which
masks your location by routing you
through servers in other countries
did you know that streaming services
have different libraries for different
regions
they're just playing games at this point
am i right surf shark can bypass all
that nonsense
say you're on netflix in the us and you
want to watch your favorite show
the office as you can see it's not
available
guess that means you can't watch it
right wrong
all you've got to do is open
surfsharkvpn switch to another server
like the uk
and bam go ahead and watch the office to
your heart's delight
you're not just limited to one device
either surfshark can be installed and
used on an
unlimited number of devices if you're
interested go to the link in the
description below and enter promo code
asylum
you'll get 83 off and three extra months
for free
which is a good deal it'll also let
surfshark know you heard about them for
me
which helps out the channel so
what's the coldest you've ever been
please share in the comments
thanks for liking and sharing this video
a special thanks goes out to patreon
patrons like joseph salamoni
and youtube members like l wayne
osbrooks for their very generous support
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember
it's okay to be a little crazy
the featured comment comes from chingam
fong who brought up an interesting point
about the rate at which space expands
compared to the passage of time
yes the boltzmann universe has problems
it's a little outdated
i was just hoping to use it as a
launching point for more modern cyclic
models
anyway thanks for watching